today on the matt wall show a hollywood
actress delivers a groveling apology to
the mob
despite having done absolutely nothing
wrong that always goes well doesn't it
meanwhile a prominent
psychiatrist who publicly fantasized
about murdering white people
doubled down and refused to apologize
this happened on the same day
what can we learn from this interesting
contrast also five headlines including
an msnbc analyst
saying that she saw some american flags
over the weekend and was
disturbed by them that's a direct quote
also
the biden administration officially
adopts the birthing people label to
describe women
and trump says he's considering ron
desantis as a vp in 2024 i think that's
a terrible idea and i'll explain plus in
our daily cancellation
the actress monique gets into some hot
water for criticizing people for
dressing like slobs in public but she's
right of course there is a slob epidemic
in america and we'll talk about that and
much more today
on the matt wall show
welcome again to the show a quick note
to begin uh this show has grown
quite a bit over the past year or so
granted we had nowhere to go but up when
we started with me screaming at my
dashboard
in my car but even so we are uh now one
of the fastest growing podcasts in the
country
and we'd like to keep it going and one
way you can help us do that is to go to
itunes sorry that's apple podcast
i've been told that only boomers call it
itunes now so go to apple podcast
subscribe and very important if you like
the show leave a five star review
that's a that is one thing you could do
to really help the show i'm over here
raising money for
boilers so frankly this is the least you
can do for me you owe me
now on to the topic at hand and it's a
topic that begins sadly with another i
told you so
um ellie kemper is a popular hollywood
actress and star of the unbreakable
kimmy schmidt and other things i haven't
seen
you may recall last week when photos
resurfaced quote unquote i.e were
searched for and found and posted by
someone with a vendetta
of kemper at the age of 19 in 1999
taking part in something called the
veiled profit ball
she had the honor of being crowned the
queen of love and beauty a title that
many people in the audience often apply
to me as it happens
22 years later it was decided by the
woke mob that the event was actually
racist
and was in fact not only racist but a
literal kkk event
that was the claim the woke mob last
week
began calling kemper a kkk princess
and slandering her as a member of the
clan
this was all completely made up ellie
kemper starter of the unbreakable kimmy
schmidt
is as it turns out not a member of the
clan
who would have thought the event was not
clan affiliated at all
even a little it also wasn't racist
apparently the veiled prophet's ball had
been
around since the 19th century and it
used to exclude black people and jews
but it integrated in 1979 that's a year
before kemper was even born
and there's no reason that she would
have known about that as a 19 year old
who just wanted to wear a fancy dress
and go to a ball
and even if she did know about it so
what
literally any institution that's been
around for more than a century
will have a history of of unenlightened
racial views
and that's not just the case in america
but everywhere
okay take any institution created in the
19th century or earlier
and you will find that the people who
established it had views on race
and not just on race but everything else
that we would find
objectionable today so by the standard
being applied to kemper
anyone affiliated with any event or
institution or organization or function
that existed for more than a few decades
should apologize i mean we could start
with anyone who's ever attended a
professional baseball game do you know
i'm sure you know about
the history of professional baseball and
race
you ever gone one of those games i i'll
need your apologies in writing
you're basically a member of the kkk
but i don't say any of this in order to
defend ellie kemper
i say it only because it's true i'm
simply telling you the facts
as i said last week i'm i'm not
interested in defending ellie kemper
because
she's been a vocal proponent of blm she
has helped to feed the beast
she has bowed to the altar of the race
hustlers she has contributed
to our current racial hysteria and this
is the consequence
and as if to prove my point even further
kemper yesterday
issued the expected apology and it it is
as
groveling and sycophantic and nauseating
as you might anticipate
kneeling before her slanderers and
apologizing for having done
absolutely nothing wrong kemper wrote in
part
quote uh the century-old organization
that hosted the debutante ball
had an unquestionably racist sexist and
elitist pest
i was not aware of the history at the
time but ignorance is not an excuse
i was old enough to have educated myself
before getting involved at the same time
i acknowledge that because of my race
and my privilege i am the beneficiary of
a system that has dispensed unequal
justice
and unequal rewards there's a very
natural temptation when you become the
subject of internet criticism to tell
yourself
that your detractors are getting it all
wrong but at some point last week i
realized
that a lot of the focus a lot of the
forces behind the criticism are forces
that i've spent my life supporting and
agreeing with
if my experience is an indication that
organizations and institutions with past
that fall short of these beliefs
should be held to account then i have to
see this experience in a positive light
well yes there it is she stumbled on the
truth
but drew the wrong conclusion from it
she says
that the people attacking her are people
she spent her life supporting and
agreeing with
exactly ellie you supported them and to
thank you for your support they tore you
to shreds as
sport they tried to ruin your life and
your career
for nothing nobody was actually upset
about ellie kemper nobody cared
no one was offended by this ball that no
one had even heard of before
last week none of them cared
it didn't mean anything to them but they
thought they'd ruin your life anyway or
try to
maybe that should tell you something
ellie about those people and their
causes
she also says that ignorance is no
excuse which is a common refrain
in these gutless self-flagellating
apologies but in fact
just so you know ignorance is a great
excuse it's actually one of the best
excuses you can offer for something
in this case there's nothing to be
excused for because again she didn't do
anything wrong by attending the ball
yet putting that aside just as a general
concept if someone does something that's
actually wrong
and they don't know that it's wrong
they're ignorant
and they didn't intend to do anything
wrong then their ignorance
would in fact mitigate their moral
culpability significantly
depending on what the thing is it may
not get them off the hook entirely in
terms of consequences
but it is an excuse and a pretty good
one
i only make this point because the
ignorance is no excuse thing
goes hand in hand with the idea that
intent doesn't matter
you know if you say or do something and
someone else feels offended by it all
that matters is how they
feel your own personal intentions are
irrelevant
and that's totally backwards but this is
all a mood point
kemper apologized and in apologizing she
admits guilt
she essentially confesses to a sin she
didn't commit
that's what happens when you apologize
it's like if you're if you're
brought in for murder and you're you
know
in the in the in the interrogation room
with the cops
and you didn't commit murder but you
start apologizing to them
oh dear god i'm so sorry i'm sorry well
that's going to be seen as an omission
of guilt
so she assumed guilt that is not her own
in order to appease the mob
a mob which cannot be appeased and which
will still happily rip her to pieces and
throw her into the trash
because she is nothing to them
so that happened it could be educational
meanwhile to compare this story to
another one
unfolding at the same time we discussed
yesterday the controversy surrounding
dr aruna kilanani a prominent
psychiatrist who gave a lecture to the
yale school of medicine
which was one long racist diatribe
against white people
the most racist part of the racist rant
and it's actually kind of hard to pick
the most racist part because the entire
thing is racist
but uh the most racist part probably is
when she confessed to having a strong
urge to shoot white people in the head
and she says that she could do this blow
a white person's brains out just because
they're white
and walk away whistling joyously with a
pep in her step
in other words she is a murderous
bloodthirsty insane
anti-white bigot and is proud of it
the audio of this lecture was posted
online deserved outrage
ensued none of that outrage coming from
the left of course
and yesterday around the time that ellie
kemper was apologizing for going to a
dance in 1999
dr aruna came out with her own statement
doubling down
and refusing to apologize she wrote
quote
too much of the discourse on race is a
dry bland regurgitation of new
vocabulary words with no work in the
unconscious
and if you want to hit the unconscious
you will have to feel
real negative feelings my speaking
metaphorically about my own anger was a
method for people to reflect on negative
feelings to normalize negative feelings
because if you don't it will turn into a
violent action
something is emotionally dangerous about
opening up a conversation about race no
one wants to look at their actions or
face their own negative feelings about
what they're doing
the best way to control the narrative is
to focus on me and make me the problem
which is what i stated occurs in the
dynamic racism my work is important and
i stand by it
we need to heal in this country she
stands by it
she stands by her desire to shoot white
people in the face
in fact more than stands by she wants to
normalize those feelings she wants uh
more people to talk about it she wants
them to be unashamed to talk about it
publicly
not only is she not sorry she's proud
her work with hating white people and
wanting to kill white people is
important she says and it will
it will heal the country
there you have it the woman who did
nothing wrong
and was smeared as a racist apologized
the woman who actually is a racist and
proudly so
does not apologize and the reason it
works this way
is that the real crime ellie kemper
committed what's the real crime
it's that she's white being white
is the crime that in the end is what she
was apologizing for
it's what the mob wants all white people
to apologize for
and keep apologizing forever
you can play that game if you want you
can live your life on your knees begging
constantly for forgiveness for sins you
didn't commit
or you can look the mob square in the
face and say go to hell
i apologize for nothing
those are really your only two choices
now
there is no in between road available
and i know which one i choose now let's
get to our five headlines
now a word from my pillow you know i had
a my pillow related
uh catastrophe um or
emergency a couple days ago because i
couldn't find my my pillow i went a few
days without it sleeping
couldn't find it anywhere and then i
discovered that one of my kids had
stolen it
and went off to their room with it and
of course i i took it back and i gave
them the bad pillow took the my pillow
for myself because it's important for me
to be though i have to be the one
who gets the most sleep i'm you know i'm
bringing in the bacon anyway so
um the reason why you need a my pillow
just like i do is that
they don't go flat you can wash and dry
them as many times as
as you need to and they maintain their
shape and best of all
they're made right here in the usa if
you don't have a my pillow or you know
someone who doesn't
now's the time to get one because for a
limited time my pillow is offering their
premium my pillows
for their lowest price ever you can get
a queen size premium my pillow
which is normally 69.98 for only 29.98
that's 40
in savings kings are only five dollars
more now's the time to buy
not only getting the lowest price ever
but they're the best gifts ever also so
go to mypillow.com and click on the
radio listener square
use promo code dailywire you also get
deep discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets or call
800-951-7163 news promo code dailywire
visit mypillow.com now
or call 800-951-7163
so we'll start here actually i wanted to
s
i wanted to to play this during the
opening but i didn't have time
speaking of the racist murderous
psychiatrist
um here is i just want to show you this
is an example
of the kind of stuff this wacko puts out
there
um and it's it's it's this is why it's
important it's not just the kind of
thing that this whack job puts out there
into the world
it's what a lot of psychiatrists
and and quote mental health
professionals
are saying and telling their patients
so let's just watch this so part of the
disconnect
in white culture is that americans think
that they're at the top of the food
chain and the most
free so white female therapists often
need to think of themselves as very
feminist
so they don't really actually have an
idea that women from other countries
are actually doing really well they're
incredibly educated they held high
status jobs
and they coming here they actually had
to take a
a lower cut an inferior job i would
point this racism out to your therapist
people often think that coming to
america is a step up and that is often
how white america
views it um and for many immigrants they
actually had to step down
lose their titles lose status make
enormous sacrifices that were incredibly
harmful
also white therapists don't often
understand that immigrant parents
tolerate the trauma of racism on a level
that they never
had before they left their home country
okay first of all put a damn battery
in your smoke detector lady
uh do you not know how to change the
batteries in your smoke detector
some women don't i've heard
uh second more important i i guess a
couple of questions
arise here and the first one is
uh coming to america is a step down
we egotistical arrogant white americans
we assume that uh that coming to america
is a step
up for immigrants
you know it and how could we possibly
arrive at that conclusion
what where where do we get off uh
making that assumption well i don't know
maybe because they're coming here
maybe because they chose to leave where
they were living before and come here
you know and so i i would assume that
for them it's a step up
if it's not a step up why are they here
maybe that's the reason so explain to me
doc if it's a step down then why the
hell
are they here
i will just say this to anyone if you
came to this country and you've
discovered that it's a step down
you're welcome to go back to wherever
you came from and that's
that's what i would do if i left my home
country and went somewhere else and i
discovered that i'd step down in the
world
i would just go back
what are you doing here in that case
see they want to have it both ways when
it comes to immigration
they want to say we you know we should
throw open the the floodgates throw open
the doors
erase the borders invite everybody in
and if we don't do that it's like a
human rights violation
we're committing a you know grievous
sin against these immigrants who want to
come here
so they want to say that on one hand but
on the other hand they also want to say
that it's a step down
their country's better anyway it's
racist here it's so much more racist
and they're persecuted even more no you
got to pick a lane
it's one or the other
because if it's a step down and we're
horrible to immigrants and there's so
much racism and everything is bad and
everything is terrible
and all the minorities here are just
exhausted all the time by the
persecution and everything they stop
then that's all the more reason to close
the borders and say no don't come here
it's bad here go back to where you came
from it's be a lot better for you
in fact in that case it's a i think it's
a it's a
would be an act of generosity and
charity to close the border sound
so you really got to pick a lane but
they never do
that it's really on every issue they
want to have it both ways
it it's it's all depend this is one of
the advantages of being a relativist is
that there is no objective truth so the
truth is whatever you need it to be in
the moment so
depending on what the discussion is
about if the discussion is about
the border specifically and immigration
then
yeah this is a better life and let
everybody come if the discussion is
about systemic racism then america is a
hell hole you know it just it really
depends it's whatever they need it to be
in the moment
it doesn't matter if their
talking points line up uh with each
other
and she says that that um you know
there's more racism
here than in the countries where
these people are coming from really can
you can you tell me
which let's talk for a second about
you know because i assume we're talking
about
non-white predominantly non-white
countries
i mean if these are immigrants who are
coming here and experience racism
then i assume we're not talking about
immigrants from you know from
from a predominantly white country um
even though of course immigrants from
predominantly white countries in the in
the past
have come here for example irish
immigrants italian
have come here and experienced bigotry
but i assume that's not what she's
talking about
so um i guess i would i would like to
know
give me an example of a predominantly
non-white
country somewhere else in the world
that is more racially tolerant than the
united states of america
that is more racially enlightened and
tolerant than the united states of
america
can you give me an example because i
don't think you can
i really don't
give give me an example of a non-white
country
that is more accepting of of diversity
more progressive more racially tolerant
than the united states
i mean where are these countries that
you're referring to
and where in fact you can be even more
successful and you can climb the ladder
even better
and live the dream and the problem is if
you can name that country then again the
question remains
why would anyone leave there to come
here
all right let's go to number two mara
gay who we mentioned last week
for some dumb things she said and i
can't even remember what it was but it
doesn't matter
she was on msnbc saying more dumb things
and
uh this time she had some thoughts on
the american flag now
i i saw this clip being posted on on
twitter
by conservatives and they were quoting
her as saying
that that she saw the american flag and
it was disturbing
her and i actually i don't know i'm
still optimistic and i try to see the
best in people you know that about me
so i actually before i clicked on the
clip i thought
you know are they did she really say
that exactly or she just sort of
implying it
did she actually come out and say that
directly um
i even had a little bit of skepticism
but it turns out no that's exactly what
she said
let's listen the reality is here
that we have a large percentage of the
american population
i don't know how big it is but we have
tens of millions of trump voters
who continue to believe that
their rights as citizens are under
threat by simple virtue of having to
share the democracy with others
i think as long as they see
americanness as the same as one
with whiteness this is going to continue
we have to figure out
how to get every american a place at the
table in this democracy
but how to separate american-ness
america from whiteness until we can
confront that
and talk about that this is really going
to continue i was on long island this
weekend
uh visiting a really dear friend and i
was really disturbed i saw
you know dozens and dozens of pickup
trucks with
uh you know uh explicatives against joe
biden
on the back of them uh trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know uh is also just
disturbing because essentially the
message was clear it was
this is my country okay
so she saw pickup trucks with
with uh all you have to do is laugh at
that all you can do is just laugh she
saw pickup trucks and she was disturbed
and she saw american flags and she was
disturbed
just think about the bubble these people
live in
they they really do
you know that's not just some populist
cliche but these are elitists
who live in a bubble and they go outside
of that bubble
and they are horrified by normal things
like pickup trucks
i'm just imagining maura gay you know
walking down the street seeing a pickup
truck and crumpling down on the sidewalk
in tears
oh my god what is that thing what is
that
and she was disturbed by the american
flag as well
she's very clear about that you know
it's it we think back to
colin kaepernick when he began his
protest
after he was benched and you know his
nfl career was falling apart and and
that's when he discovered his uh
his passion for social justice and
activism total coincidence of course but
and uh he started doing his whole thing
we were originally told that
that it was not a protest of the flag
it's not a protest of the anthem it's
all a protest of
of police brutality for years that's
what we were told
meanwhile many of us mostly on the right
we we from the very beginning pegged
this as
no he's protesting the flag that's what
he's doing
um this is not about police brutality
and for years and years the left told us
that's that's uh that's a libelous
charge it's not true
well now they're pretty open about it
they actually just hate the flag itself
and they hate what it represents
they hate the fact that when someone's
flying the flag they're saying this is
my country well yeah
mara that is what they're saying and it
is their country
okay if you're an american it's your
country they're americans they're flying
the american flag
now let's go here number three trump
was on fox yesterday and he was asked
about the possibility of
of having ron desantis as his vice
presidential
as his running mate in 2024 and he said
he was he was open to the idea first
let's listen to trump uh talking about
that
if you were to run for the presidency in
2024
would you consider ron desantis governor
of florida as your running mate
sure i would but you know there are
numerous people that are great i would
certainly consider ron
i was i was at the beginning of ron i
was the first one to endorse him
when he came out as a congressman that a
lot of people didn't know and
my endorsement helped him tremendously
and i know him very well he's a great
guy
we have other great people i mean you
look at some of the people that
republican people that have done a great
job with states
and you don't see that with the
democrats i mean they kept their states
closed and locked down
and the schools are closed it's just
absolutely outrageous how they get away
with it
uh yeah
i i just want to say i mean there's no
indication that
that ron desantis is interested in this
and in fairness
he was he was asked would you consider
him and so he said yeah
and uh what else is he going to say he's
not going to say no i wouldn't consider
it so
can't blame him for giving that answer
um
this is far from concern from confirming
that it's an actual
thing that's that that might happen and
i would assume that ron desantis
wouldn't be on board for that i hope he
wouldn't because
this would be a terrible idea to have
ron desantis as trump's
running mate you talk about a waste of
talent you're going to take the most
effective
effective executive level politician
effective governor in the country
i mean the most effective republican
politician
at any level i think and make him
a figurehead make him a
a vice president who does nothing
terrible idea and the reason it's worth
addressing is because i see this a lot
online there's there's definitely a
feeling out there among trump supporters
they would love to see this happen
i see a lot of trump desantis 2024
things online
terrible awful idea if desantis
is not running in 2024 if he's not
interested in being president
or running for president 2024 then he
needs to stay governor of florida
where he's done such a phenomenal job
the last thing we need is for him to be
vice president for trump
and the other thing also to keep in mind
is that trump
has an extensive history of uh
hiring people to work for him and then
within a few years
he hates that person and they're at each
other's throats and
and all of that i mean that's that's the
way it almost always goes
with like every person trump hires who's
not in his family
i know you might be able to think of a
few exceptions but not many
and if that were to happen to desantis
it would just sort of sully his
political brand and um and that's the
last thing we need
now what really needs to happen is ron
desantis
if he decides he wants to stay governor
of florida that's fine but
if he's interested then ron desantis
should run in 2024 and he should be the
guy
and donald trump if he cares about the
cause if he cares about the movement
he would get behind desantis not as vice
president but he would
endorse him and tell all of his
supporters to go to ron desantis
you know desantis is is the future of
the republican party
donald trump who would be 78 in 2024
he's not
and putting everything else aside i i
have been very clear and consistent
that i do not think and i said this with
biden and it wasn't just because it's
but there are a lot of reasons to oppose
biden and there were
during the campaign but
we could just start and end it with his
age 78 years old
is way too old and we're seeing this
right now
78 years old is way too old to run for
president it just is you're gonna you're
gonna be turning
80 in the presidency that that is old
for a pope
okay that's even like pope level old
and if it counts as old for a pope it's
too old for a president
and i know the response is that well
trump is different and he's got a lot
more energy and everything
yeah he does but uh he is a mortal human
being like the rest of us
and there are just physical realities
and one of them
is that your mind and your body
deteriorate as you get older
and when you get into your 80s or close
to it that process
really kicks into high gear for everyone
you don't you there's no getting away
from that or around it
so let's not do that please
more political news the biden
administration is now officially
referring to women
as birthing people so
here's biden in uh their their budget
proposal
he says uh talking about his budget
proposal just reading the language it
says it reduces the maternal mortality
rate and ends
race-based disparities in maternal
mortality the united states
has the highest maternal mortality rate
among developed nations
with an unex unacceptably high mortality
rate for black american indian alaskan
native
and other women of color to help end
this high rate of maternal
mortality and race-based disparities and
outcomes among birthing people
and then it goes it goes from there uh
birthing people
now of course he still uses the word
maternal
and you know maternal it maternal means
relating to a mother that's what it
means
so you still say that but you can't say
mother anymore we have to say birthing
people
the democrat party continuing to um
erase women
i mean in in a you know in a very
literal sense or as literal as they
possibly can
they are they're trying to destroy and
undermine
the concept of womanhood
and for so long we've feminists have
accused
republicans of doing that
you're racing women
and here's here's what that and for a
long time
when uh when feminists in the left
accuse republicans of doing that and of
course it was totally nonsense
but i along probably with you i i always
thought what do you mean erasing women
what would that even look like oh okay
well this is what it looks like
and it's uh pretty disturbing the
american flag is not disturbing but this
is
all right next we have um greta thunberg
issued another proclamation condemning
all of us for our selfishness
and she does this periodically
periodically i mean like three times a
week
so if this is a long one it went on for
like five minutes
um but we'll play a little bit of it and
and this portion i thought was funny
primarily just because she talks about
the thoughts and feelings of fish
and how we have to respect their
thoughts and feelings so let's listen
and finally the animals every year
we kill more than 60 billion animals
excluding fish whose numbers are so
great
that we only measure their lives by
weight
what about their thoughts and feelings
some animals plan for the future forge
friendships
that last for decades they play
they help each other they show signs
of what we call empathy but 70
of the animals we farm live inside
factories
in the united states that number is 99
their lives are short and terrible
[Music]
how will we be judged
it is heartbreaking to know all this but
it is also our opportunity
we know what we can do we can change the
way we farm
we can change what we eat we can change
how we treat nature some of us
have lots of choices while some have
none at all
those with the most power have the most
responsibility
and most of us can do something
so what will you do
um nothing i'm not gonna do anything i'm
just
i'm being totally honest with you greta
i'm not going to do anything at all
about these problems that you have
outlined um
[Music]
and i'm not even denying that some of
them you know
in a perfect world would i if i were
setting up my perfect world would it
include
factory farming no
what am i going to do about it nothing
really
and part of that is you know you people
have taken this on as your cause
but it's and there's there are a lot of
you know a lot of complaints a lot of
criticisms
but really short on solutions
so just saying we can change let's
change the way we eat
let's change this and that in what way
exactly
and you got to be real specific
because we you know we got a lot of
people to feed in this country
300 plus mill 330 million people
and counting especially because as we
discussed earlier
the borders being poorest people people
more and more people
pouring in here every day and that's
more and more people to feed
a lot of mouths to feed
so what's your plan for making sure that
all those people get fed cicadas
you think we're all going to live on
worms i mean what is your plan exactly
and uh also just so you know
uh fish don't don't really have thoughts
or feelings
at all um they're they're basically like
biological machines so you don't you
don't have to worry too much about how
the fish are feeling because
they're not really feeling anything they
don't they don't have the neurological
equipment for that
all right you know who who uh here's a
group that does have feelings that would
be
uh babies little children that's
something the left probably needs to be
reminded
so i want to do a little parenting
advice here quickly before i move on to
youtube comments emily ratajkowski whose
name i can never pronounce exactly but
she's a super supermodel she just had a
baby three months ago
and she's back to posting
video or photos of herself in bikini
she's back in
posing in bikinis again and we have the
photo here she is
this was on sports illustrated posted
this and here she is holding her
three-month-old
baby her son i believe that's her son
and i could be wrong about this
but didn't she say wasn't she one of the
people who said that she was going to
raise her kid to be gender neutral or
something maybe i'm wrong i think she
said that
this doesn't look like a gender-neutral
kid to me
but more to the point okay so she's got
the bikini on she's showing off the
bikini bod
holding her baby there as an accessory
but the way she's holding that baby i
just want you to know
okay and it's it's a problem when i'm
the one who has to give these lessons on
how to hold babies
but i've had four of them so i've
learned a thing or two you do not hold a
baby like that
someone teach this chick how to hold a
baby she's gonna
cause serious damage to this child
this is you know how she she's holding
the kid this is how my one-year-old
holds her baby dolls my one-year-old
will walk around the house holding her
baby doll like that around with her arm
like that
like basically around the neck and
sometimes she'll vary in a very
nurturing way she'll be feeding her
fake uh baby bottle to the baby doll
and then she'll get bored and she'll
just chuck the baby doll across the room
i hope that uh emily doesn't do that to
her kid but anyway you don't hold a baby
like that
way too much pressure you need to
support the neck this is a
three-month-old kid
they don't have all the muscles and
everything in the neck to hold their
heads up and their heads
you know babies their heads are way too
big for their bodies so that's why you
got to put a lot of support behind the
neck
and in the photo on the right there
she's putting way too much pressure on
his left arm
i mean you're gonna rip his arm out of
its socket
that just concerns me as a parent but
this is what happens
when you see your child more as a
fashion accessory
than as a human being
all right let's move on now to reading
the youtube comments
mateo says speaking of the abuela
fundraiser this is officially the nicest
internet troll of all time
is matt's heart thawing after all this
time
well like we said yesterday it's it's
the nicest it's also the meanest
it's nice it's mean it's petty it's
generous generous
it's all of those things at once it is
all things to all people
um another comment says a ton of people
saying
this was a huge fail etc don't listen to
them
i thought it was brilliant yeah there is
a there was a minority of voices on the
right
especially now of course people on the
left were upset about it because they
were going to be upset no matter what i
do
but there's a minority of voices on the
right
who have been very critical of the
abuela fundraiser
very critical of it and very outraged
and offended that i did it
and uh but they could never quite
they could never quite settle on what
their criticism was what problem they
had with it
what i kept hearing over and over again
over the last few days what i've heard a
million times from some people on the
right
is uh what are you i've heard two things
first of all what are you raising money
for the enemy
okay abuela is not my enemy
she's a sweet old woman presumably
she aoc's grandmother is not my enemy
that's the first thing
and the other thing i heard is what are
you doing this this for
when there are all these other issues
that that need our attention
why is this the most important thing to
you why are you talking about this
rather than this thing over here and
whenever someone goes for that you know
they're just
they're grasping for a criticism
so i think there are some people on the
right they don't like me for whatever
reason i can't imagine why they wouldn't
like me
um and so they they see that we're doing
this
and that it's successful and it's
getting some attention and they want to
not like it and they're looking for a
reason and so they go with
what are you doing that instead of this
thing that is always the lamest
criticism
yes at any you see at any given moment
of time as humans
we choose one thing or another to do or
to talk about
we can't do everything all at once we
can't talk about everything all the time
and just because i'm talking about this
one thing or doing this one thing in
this moment
it doesn't mean i'm saying it's the most
important thing in the world
in fact all of us spend much of our days
doing and saying things that are not the
most important things
it'd be like if i you know if i saw you
i don't know uh eating a a bologna
sandwich
and i ran up to you and said what are
you doing sitting here eating a bologna
sandwich
and i had a whole list of other things
you could be doing with your time in
that moment
it's just the weirdest criticism
uh let's see mrs lopez says
no relation or maybe there's relation i
don't know i knew regardless of the
outcome of the gofundme matt had proven
several points
one aoc is a narcissistic selfish and
ungrateful politician
two she didn't want a solution she just
used her abuela to strike political
points
three the left is obsessed with blaming
donald trump for everything for matt
walsh is a genius well
i'll take i don't know about the first
three but number four i'll take
um stank williams jr great screen name
sir username says matt i'll i'll see
your honeybee toilet prank and raise you
with the always hilarious
asian murder hornet pinata at a kid's
birthday party
my kids just had a birthday party with a
pinata and i can tell you right now
if i filled a pinata with with murder
hornets my sons would think it was the
coolest thing ever
that wouldn't be much of a prank at all
ashley says troll anthropos
matt you're my hero yeah i did coin that
term i wish i had thought of it during
the show but uh i have
now i want to be on the record i'm
officially coining the term
troll anthropy uh and i think someone
should start a website like troll fund
me or something
for trolling charity campaigns it's
pretty niche i don't know how many
campaigns there will really be but
alexis says
i am 19 and recently started a nine to
five even though i'm new here i find
that there is something so satisfying
about working hard
knowing that you earned every dollar you
got and the things you buy stem from
that dedication
you know that you don't owe anyone
anything i could never live in a
socialist society
because i would feel like a grown adult
being spoon-fed like a baby
and that's just not a good feeling i get
paid good money to do my job i earn
every penny
not by being sloppy or complaining but
by performing my tasks to the very best
of my ability
with a good attitude that's encouraging
and i'll read you one more encouraging
one
micah says i'm 20 and started a trade in
plumbing a year in and i've gotten two
raises from my boss because there's such
a lack of workers right now especially
in the trades i've really started to
like it and making a good amount of
money
while doing so people my age need to
start looking at not being afraid of
studying and work yeah this is a good
this is the this is the right attitude
uh and it's it's
disturbing you know i mean they're
always
everyone is prone to laziness you always
find that especially among young people
and all people so
there's nothing especially unique about
that
but what i find uh distressing in in
younger people especially
unlike micah and alexis here a lot of
younger people they don't really seem to
have a great desire for independence
which is so foreign to me because i know
that when i was a teenager
and i had a good family life and
everything but even so i it was
just natural i wanted to get out there
have a job have my own place and when i
finally had that even though i wasn't
making a lot of money and i lived in a
crummy apartment and everything it it
was great i was thrilled because i had
that independence
and for me that was natural to desire
that but i think for a lot of younger
people now they don't have that desire
it's one of the reasons why
also in my generation we were really
excited to drive
and we wanted as soon as we hit the
whatever the age requirement was in our
state we wanted to get that learner's
permit we wanted to drive
and you see the age of driving
not because of the laws but because of
choices
the age of driving has gone up and up in
recent years because
a lot of younger people don't really
care about driving they have nowhere
they want to go
they're fine sitting in their house
i see i'm glad to see that's not the
case for everyone though
now we check in with trust and will you
know if you
have dependents people depend on you
children spouse
what have you then it's not only
important to have a will but it's really
a moral obligation i think
i think and uh if you want to set up a
will at trustedwill.com setting up an
estate plan is simple convenient and
secure for as little as 39
you can nominate guardians for your
children you can determine who gets your
stuff and plan for future medical care
all from the comfort of your home
trusting wheel documents are designed by
estate planning experts and customized
for the state that you live in
and with live customer support seven
days week trustandwheel.com team is
available
to answer any questions you have while
you're setting up your plan trust and
will is a most
trusted name in online estate planning
the category leader on trustpilot and
they've helped hundreds of thousands of
people protect their families assets
and legacies and it's very easy to do
and also affordable
so if you want to gain peace of mind at
trustedwill.com
then uh go to crustalwheel.com walsh and
get 10 off plus free shipping
of your customized legal documents don't
wait go right now
this is very important get 10 off plus
free shipping at trustandwill.com
walsh again that's trustandwill.com
walsh
and uh you know great advances in modern
technology may have made sure that a
world of information is always at your
fingertips but if you don't have the
daily wire app
that world is far from complete download
the daily wire app and be the first in
the know with top tier political
commentary
from your favorite conservatives like
myself and
others you'll find more than 100 news
articles a month
fresh video content daily and so much
more just subscribe to the daily wire
download the app and arm yourself with
the facts and logic you need for every
unfortunate leftist encounter you may
have in the american wild
go there now and do that now let's get
to our daily cancellation
so the actress monique recently got
herself into hot water because of
comments
she made about the way according to her
some black women dress and present
themselves
in public she was inspired to offer this
criticism after noticing lots of
slovenly attire at the airport
she spoke about the issue for several
minutes and then did a follow-up video
further explaining it but
here's some of the original instagram
posts let's watch
and as we begin to walk through the
airport
i saw so many actually too many to count
and too many for me to tap but i saw so
many of our young sisters
in head bonnets scarves
slippers pajamas
blankets wrapped around them and this is
how they're showing
up to the airport
and it i've been seeing it
not just at the airport i've been seeing
it at the store at the mall
i've been seeing sisters showing up with
these bonnets and head scarves and they
slippers
and the question that i'm having to you
my sweet babies
when did we lose pride in representing
ourselves
now after watching that i'm beginning to
think i need to start
softening some of my more controversial
takes by calling the audience sweet
babies
seems to work for monique something
tells me it wouldn't work as well for me
as for the point she's making she's
right and this isn't just about black
women this is a problem that extends
equally across all sexes
all of them all 95 sexes all races in
fact
it's maybe the one thing that still
unites us as americans is our one source
of unity that we dress like hobos
in public especially at airports
airports now look like refugee camps
with people
sprout out all over the place laying
across seats on the floor wrapping
themselves in old newspaper
using a half-eaten bag of chips as a
pillow everyone's wearing pajamas
they have their shoes off exposing their
gnarled fungus-crusted toes to the world
it's unseemly disgusting and it's made
all the worse by the fact
that all of us have paid way too much
money for the privilege of being tossed
in with this gang of
foul-smelling circus freaks now you see
this sort of thing everywhere
as monique rightly points out at the
store walking down the street
everywhere i saw a guy the other day at
the grocery store wearing fuzzy bear
slippers as in slippers
that looked like teddy bears as he
walked around the frozen food aisle
this man was older than me by the way
his attire was
an unholy mix of infantilizing and
bedraggled
childish and disheveled now for
comparison
go back and look at old photos taken of
any random
busy pedestrian area in say 1935.
all the men are dressed in hats and
suits all the women are wearing dresses
everybody looks like they just came out
of church
all the time now take that same street
and get a snapshot from
yesterday in the year 2021 and
everyone's adorned like a bunch of
nine-year-olds at a slumber party in
fact
get a snapshot of them walking out of
church what few still attend
and they probably still look like
nine-year-olds at a slumber party i saw
a guy at church recently in a
batman t-shirt and shorts
if that's what he considers dressing up
i'd hate to see what he wears to the
airport probably
naked with just a bathrobe and socks
with no shoes which at least would make
it easier when he goes through security
admittedly
of course many people including monique
have pointed all this out before
it's well known and understood that
people go out in public
looking like half-melted slugs i mean we
become a nation of pajama-clad oafs that
much is known
but what's interesting is to compare
this to the way that people present
themselves online
you know most americans feel comfortable
walking around in a three-dimensional
public space
with uncombed hair unbrushed teeth
sweatpants they just pulled out of a
dumpster
but most of those same people wouldn't
be caught dead
on instagram looking like that this
could be an interesting experiment if a
bit stalkerish but it would be
fascinating to see
a person you know walking out of target
looking like they were just in there
sleeping on the bathroom floor for the
past nine hours
and then find that same person on
instagram and see the sort of image they
put
out into the world it is guaranteed to
be quite a bit different
now in fairness it is easier requires
less effort to present yourself as well
kempt and attractive online
because you only have to worry about
what you look like for the half a second
it takes to snap a picture
and then you can alter it in post if you
need to
uh one must expend more energy for a
longer period of time to look suitable
in the real world you have to do things
like
you know shower iron your shirt put on
pants it's not much effort but it's some
effort and some
is more than a lot of people are willing
to give but i think there's more to it
aside from the effort it seems that
these days we simply don't
value in-person interaction the way that
we value
our interactions with avatars online i
mean the classic example of this that
everyone points
to all the time and the most depressing
also is the infamous sight of a family
at a restaurant sitting around a table
silently
while they all interact with strangers
through their phones
i think the poor dress in public is part
and parcel with this it speaks to our
inability to recognize the value of
other humans
and of human to human interchange unless
it's mediated by a digital device
it's common to hear someone defend their
embarrassing attire and disgusting
appearance
and is what some of the people were
saying to monique saying that well you
know i don't care what anyone thinks
it's none of their business except that
you do care what other people think
you care tremendously it's just that you
only seek approval of
strangers in cyberspace see it's not
a matter of not caring about people's
opinions it's a matter of which people's
opinions they choose to care about
and for so many they choose the internet
strangers rather than humans that they
encounter face to face
in flesh and blood and i think that's
the wrong choice it's not just the wrong
choice
it's deeply disordered and dehumanizing
and demeaning to everybody involved
so please everyone stop walking around
in public looking like hideous
unbathed ogres my sweet babies
also you're all canceled and we'll leave
it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. washington
state bribes potheads to get the wu flu
vacs
biden promises never to fire dr fauci
and the libertarian party proves why we
can't have nice things check it out on
the michael knowles show